on n'attend pas ici la vie tout à fait
contre c'est pas beau du tout chez moi
ça fait drôle non la mode maxima chevaux
pas certainement pas croyez pas il faut
faire le minimum c'est d'éviter les
parents
logistique dans la pente et grands
tous les mannequins c'est très bien mais
attacherons - peut-être mais suivant la
mode de 12 à fond pour la province s'est
vraiment fait un nom d'après je crois en
tenir ça soit le massif boulimie
il
elle s'intéresse à garder telle est donc
la vie des femmes en province mais au
fond des campagnes on n'ignore pas non
plus que la mode est au maxi beaucoup
jusqu'à lors c'est plus pratique puis
c'est quand même plus élégant que la
minute et n'importe qui pourrait plus
facilement prostitue maxi que du mini
déjà pour t'envoyer sais pas c'est pas
le longtemps oui en béton de savoir oui
oui les jeunes qui suivent la mode je
n'ai plus beaucoup des jeunes à la
compagnie combo vous êtes cons
personnellement je n'irai pas jusqu'au
mi mollet mais enfin je rallonge un
petit peu mais encore et surtout pour
l'hiver l'europe est un peu plus chaud
que d'habiller trois coups